but la plupart des gens sont bons
d'autres beaucoup moins
mais toi tu es vraiment une exception
alors dû rentrer et du genre
tu as toujours su improviser
ce soir c'était pas qu
[Musique]
on en a éliminé tellement de façon
prématurée
que ce soit par mama
maintiennent
on n'a jamais éliminer quelqu'un qu'il
ne méritait pas
on doit tous payés pour mes péchés un
jour ou l'autre
[Musique]
ne s'enfuira pas elle va soigner ses
blessures et ensuite le nôtre accra
quelqu'un a tué un de mes amis à cause
d'un contrat qu'il a effectuée il ya des
années en retz
je veux des réponses où je serai la
dernière personne que vous verrez
[Musique]
ne vaudrait-il pas mieux que ce mystère
ne soit jamais résolu
[Musique]
si vous continuez
vous allez mourir
je veux maintenant chance
de personne ne pourra m'empêcher
vous êtes intrigués par l curieux
c'est très impoli non
j'aimerais beaucoup vous revoir dans
d'autres circonstances ce sens les
meilleures circonstances dans lesquelles
vous ne verrez jamais
champagne tranquille tous l'aider
maman tu disais que tu viendrais dormir
à la maison un de ces jours et pour les
occurrences c'est aujourd'hui
bon aller 2 2 mais comment ça de dos
j'ai dit ça je ne suis pas là je suis
une petite abeille
carroll car oui maman
comme ça avec ton mari si vous voulez
avoir un port pas de problème j'ai mes
boules quiès merci maman je pense que le
message est bien passé
serveur que maman est la moins de 20 cm
on entend tout ici
ces boules quiès ah oui pardon jouer à m
[Musique]
oui
tous les guerriers montrent une origine
depuis 600 ans non ninja ont apporté la
paix
dans le monde
j'ai besoin de guerriers comme toi joue
à toi nous dites moi ce que je dois
faire
à partir d'ici
ce sera toi de choisir ta route
[Musique]
mais ce n'est que le commencement
amis
frères et soeurs
qui peut
nous divertir mois et marraines en nous
racontant un mythe
ou une légende
[Musique]
au plus grand droit
permettait à un bruit alliés essayé de
porter un coup contre moi accordez moi
le plaisir de ce jeu je porterai ce coup
[Applaudissements]
dans
un nom
une année c'est presque coulé
ils te font le trouver n'était ce pas
juste un jeu peut-être mais il n'est pas
terminée
d'une aura droit à aucune pitié
et de fait l'heureuse
pourquoi tu m'arrête la fin est
imminente
repose toi maintenant je finirai cette
quête pour toi
français
et que ce père tu obtenir
en affrontant tout ça
l'honneur
c'est la raison d'être de tout chevalier
tu es prêt
[Musique]
pourquoi est ce que tu fais ton ordi
chaque fois que je rappliquent
tu
as l'air stressé
[Musique]
c'est un peu la folie au boulot
j'ai toujours voulu changer le monde
comment
amazon
pour la drogue sauf qu'on peut pas
acheter de drogue sur internet et
schiste est possible
je vais me faire 75000 dollars en
bitcoin
en une heure et demie
ça fait un million deux par jour
ce met ses premiers millennials de gens
vous avez la résoudre à l'ancien agent
bowden
tout ce qu'ils savent ils ont appris sur
un écran
ils se sont jamais fait partie de leur
vie
l'expérience est primordiale tant
est que vous l'aurez attraper envoyez
moi un fax
le darknet un arrivage spécial dans ma
boîte aux lettres
règles sont en train de changer ça va
arroser tous les quartiers d'amérique
ce site web mais qu'un vulgaire du fait
que nous serons à terme et
donc
c'est moi qui ai réussir au final à
faire tomber ce connard
situe saute le pas
tu pourras plus jamais revenue en
arrière
devient obsessionnel qui n'est ce pas
qu'ils en arrivent à le faire tomber la
complicité de meurtre échec et mat
petits intérêts spear à sion
qu'est ce que tu fous avec mon pognon
le site nous survivra à tous
à
combien de soldats se trouvent dans
l'entrepôt
puissant l'armée japonaise y verra un
geste de provocation tous les regards de
shanghai seront tournés vers nous demain
l'entrepôt de schirrhein et notre ultime
bastion ce lieu constituera notre
tombeau à tous
frère de laquelle points 8e division
grâce à vous shanghai est encore libre
votre mission est de survivre tant que
l'inde nous sera encore en vie l'espoir
demeurera pour cette nation
[Musique]
sow
écoutez moi
[Applaudissements]
charaf
c'est pour bientôt
c'est du gaz toxiques
tout
jamais arrivé de te demander si tu étais
du bon côté
ont franchi toutes les lignes à jour ou
l'autre témoin
plus ou moins
ça fait pas de démence pour autant
[Musique]
tu rétabli dans ses fonctions ça tombe
bien parce que là on en a fait autrement
dit on pas mal de monde qui t'attend au
tournant et qui révoltera masse est
terminée c'est personnel dans les coûts
et tu fais tout dans les règles
je suis bien fait comprendre quatre ans
joli discours comment
qu est-ce qu charge des eaux
rassemblés en guetta pour monter par
rapport
nature à trouver
c'est vous voir et qu'on plonge tous
avec vous
je suis vraiment très content d'être de
retour
gagnez
[Musique]
de budget avant
au mieux en ce moment mais je pense que
cela pourra même si elle est
destinée la
[Musique]
torah qui proposeront subi une
mammectomie à
l'hôpital
certainement
il n'y
aura ni l'homme ni de race partie sa
[Musique]
manche initiale il faut acquérir les
actifs étudiants en gestion
juste à ça me convient pas recommandé
[Musique]
[ __ ]
à castres
[Musique]
ce qui est beaucoup
m
[Musique]
des contractuels
[Applaudissements]